usually when you look at popular science
books there's a tone of Triumph look at
what we have created look how smart we
are we're really good at this being
human inventing things thing and I was
finding this
tone I guess that
you don't see often which is we're not
as smart as we think we are
and
I kind of want to walk you through a
couple of the examples I found in which
that was the case in which we had
of everything we needed
to invent a piece of technology and then
didn't do it for a really astoundingly
long period of time and usually it was
because we were laboring under a bad
hypothesis we thought something was true
that wasn't
so the first example is this beautiful
stock footage I purchased of a compass
so
here's the compass they could have been
vented in 200 BCE this is when the
ancient Greeks started noticing they had
these lodestones that were naturally
magnetic they were actually invented in
o1000 CE which is 1200 years of time
between the two and you'll think okay
well you know compasses are pretty
complicated that's a tiny sliver of
metal balanced on a pin sandwich between
two layers of plastic I can see why that
would take some time but when the
compass was invented in China around
1000 CE first it was used for fortune
telling for 100 or so years before it
was used for navigation
and these first compasses were not the
the plastic thing I was describing if
you have a lodestone a piece of magnetic
material it's naturally going to want to
turn to point towards midnight North to
allow it to freely turn you just have to
tie your rock to a string the string
supports The Rock The Rock rotates
freely tying a rock to a string took us
over a thousand years
to figure out because we were operating
under this bad hypothesis that some
rocks are just weird
I'll give you another example
uh beautiful stock footage of a cute dog
and a stethoscope so stethoscopes could
have been invented in 300 BCE this is
when we first came up with paper they
were actually invented in oh 1816 CE the
story here is you have this Victorian
doctor uh man heterosexual
and he has a theory that the sounds that
bodies make could be diagnostic as a
medical professional and so he's been
pressing his ear to his patient's chest
and then one day he has a patient
female busty and he's like this is too
erotic for me
I simply cannot press my ear to that
chest I need to leave room for Jesus and
so
he rolls up some paper and makes the
tube uses that and discovers by accident
that the tube isolates and enhances the
sounds he's trying to hear that were in
fact Diagnostic and so it took us two
thousand years between when we could
have met the telescope and did and this
was the only example in my research that
I found of actual scientific progress
being made by someone who was too horny
to do their job properly so it did pay
off in this instance
that hypothesis paper is boring and I
hate it
another piece of technology you all
recognize these this is these are
buttons
not really a
difficult thing to figure out
so they could have invented in 2800 BCE
this is when we first found evidence of
humans tying pretty rocks and shells to
their clothing to make themselves look
nicer actually invented in around 1200
CE which is 4 000 years of space and
what's killer is that the button is a
great piece of technology it allows
clothes to be form-fitting you have to
fit them over your head it allows them
to be sturdier and
we spent 4 000 years
thinking we looked pretty good with
these nice shells attached to our shirts
when really we looked like idiots who
didn't know how a button worked did not
put a slit in the other side to seal
clothing so you know not our not our
greatest hour or four thousand years and
the bad hypothesis we had here was that
Fashion Is Never practical
give you another example this image of
milk represents the process of
pasteurization so pasteurization is a
process in which you take a food you
bring it up to almost the boiling point
then you let it cool this kills the
bacteria in the food make it much more
safer to drink milk without
pasteurization is really dangerous food
to drink when it's been left out for a
while with pasteurization it becomes one
of the safest could have invented around
10 500 BCE this when we first started
doing farming we first started having
animals we might want to drink their
milk regularly actually invented in 1117
CE and then reinvented in the 1800s by
Louis Pasteur who puts his name all over
it
eleven thousand five hundred years where
we could have had this technology and
didn't which is
I will say it I mean I'm a human so my
best friends are humans but this is
pretty embarrassing for all of us
that hypothesis food goes bad sometimes
oh well nothing we can do
one last example of this hot air
balloons
symbolizing the human dream of flight
the most uh canonical example of humans
striving to be more than what they are
we we want to fly we finally achieve it
with lighter than air flight with hot
air balloons could have been invented in
200 BCE this is where in China they come
up with paper lanterns which can fly
they have everything they need right
there actually invented in 1783 CE by
the mongolfier brothers in France and
the Fair brothers are great
because they have no idea what they're
doing they have a fire and they discover
that this sack on top elevates and they
say oh my God we just discovered Mongol
Fier gas which allows things to fly so
we'll build a big mangoffier balloon and
fill it with Mongol Fair Gas and people
be able to fly and it works
what they don't realize is that their
whole theory behind it is wrong it's
just that less dense air flows to the
top and that's what makes things fly
that's two thousand years we could have
had it and didn't but it actually gets
worse because the mongolia's first
balloon wasn't the silks you saw on the
previous slide it was a burlap sack
lined with paper and you can make a
burlap sack lined with paper out of
natural plant and animal fibers if you
knew what you were doing one person
working alone over the course of their
life could easily collect enough fiber
to make a big burlap sack line it with a
lot of paper and achieve the Eternal
dream of human flight
at any point in human history
so these were
fun things to discover about our shared
past but if you are going back in time
there are a lot of things that you can
reinvent and take the credit for and
it's not just technology there's things
in art and music that also
can be plagiarized if you want to call
it that from the present and brought
back to the past obviously with art art
styles is something that we invented and
you can take the credit for different
styles put them in different areas but
even art has technological aspects
attached to it a great example here is
perspective this is single point
perspective everything goes towards a
single vanishing point we all learned
this in art class in maybe grade one or
two it's the way to draw cool things in
3D
but the fact that single point
perspective everything goes towards a
single vanishing point
we had to figure that out and before we
figure that out
even with multiple point perspective we
had some troubles
um here's a painting from the 600 CE
where
the artist is clearly wanting to draw in
perspective but he's he's struggling a
bit you can see here the table is sort
of wonky this Vanishing points over here
this one's over here I'm not sure what's
going on with this cabinet but he
doesn't have a coherent theory of how
things receive just knows that they do
in some way without the technology of
perspective he can't draw things
properly in a realistic way and you
could argue that okay well this was this
was a style at the time everyone liked
things to look this wonky and they could
have drawn a perspective they just
didn't want to but that argument is kind
of uh undermined by noticing that when
we do figure out the rules of
perspective artists go Hog Wild for it
it happened in the Renaissance in Europe
da Vinci
1495 CE this is sort of a hard piece of
art to look at with fresh eyes because
we've all seen it so often but if you do
look at that with fresh eyes you can see
that it's about five percent
religion and 95 of like bro check it out
I can draw in perspective I got cubes or
squares on the wall I got squares on the
ceiling they're sitting at a nice
rectangle in a flat plane it is Da Vinci
showing off that he can draw a 3D
picture and make it look great it's not
just Da Vinci Raphael philosophers
famous work in the western Canon around
the same time and Raphael can draw a
friggin Cube there's one there's one
there's one there's one
these are just elongated cubes these
steps he's very excited to show off what
he's what he can do now with this new
technology and reminds me nothing more
than
of
images in like the late 80s early 90s
where he figured out Ray tracing and
everyone was doing Chrome spheres over
checkerboard patterns
or like when we when we get lens flares
to work you get a lot of that showing up
all of a sudden people like to play with
new toys